Millionen Deutsche in der Existenzangst
und die Frage was ist die Lösung im
Moment für all die die ihre gasabschläge
ihre stromabschläge nicht mehr zahlen
können da sagt Oskar Lafontaine einer
unserer Gäste heute abend wir müssen
sofort verhandeln mit Russland wir
müssen sofort verhandeln mit Putin das
ist der entscheidende weg dann spielen
wir das mal durch ja mittelhoff würden
Sie in der aktuellen Situation
Berichterstattung über Massengräber über
immer neue Angriffe würden Sie Vladimir
Putin jetzt die Hand geben
bei Verhandlungen geht es ja erstmal
nicht um Hand gehen ja ist ja auch die
Frage wer verhandelt mit wem ich glaube
zuständig für die Lieferung von Gas
Zuteilung von Gas an ausländische
Abnehmer ist nicht Herr Putin selber
sondern er sitzt irgendeine Organisation
ja was wir konstruieren ist dass das was
wir dort abnehmen bezahlen wir mit Geld
und dieses Geld fließt einem Staat zu
der völkerrechtswidrig ein Land
überfallen finanzieren damit mit
finanzierender so also Ethik Moral
Verständnis aus westlicher Sicht stehen
gegenüber not ja und ich kann nicht
sagen wie das aufzulösen ist und wäre
ich kann nur annehmen wäre ich ein
Minister in Kabinetts Verantwortung dann
glaube ich wäre ich in letzter Sekunde
gezwungen das hört her Hofreiter jetzt
nicht gerne mein Amtseid erinnernd dass
ich alles dafür tun muss dass hier kein
Schaden entsteht also Butter war die
Fische sie würden verhandeln sie würden
fliegen nach Münster aber nicht mit
einem Putin weil das wird ja über
Terminologie schon immer kaputt gemacht
ja also da würde es doch notwendig sein
genauso wie es namens Zweiten Weltkrieg
war dass dann erstmal über Otto Wolf von
amarum gegen Dings und so weiter wurden
Geschäfte entwickelt also nicht der
Kanzler nicht der Außenminister nicht
der Wirtschaftsminister soll dann direkt
verhandeln und auch nicht direkt mit
Herrn put sagt Thomas Middelhoff
Spitzenmanager 1 wie wäre es mit Herrn
Schröder wer der dann aus ihrer Sicht
der richtige dort diesen Weg
einzuschlagen
ja das ist schon so dass Putin ja nicht
die Verhandlungen für die vergas
Lieferungen allerdings muss man sich
Klarheit darüber verschaffen er wird die
letzte Entscheidung treffen und bei der
letzten Entscheidung wird das politische
Gespräche geben müssen aber ich bin der
Meinung wer einen besseren Weg weiß wie
man die Gaspreise runter kriegt die
Strompreise Unterricht und so weiter der
soll es denn sagen und es ist ja bekannt
dass ich nicht in der politischen Fragen
mit Herrn Schröder
übereinstimme und insbesondere sozial
und wirtschaftspolitischen Frage das ist
bekannt geworden dass man eben im
vorwirft aber dass man im Vorwurf dass
er eben gute Verbindungen nach Russland
hat dies halte ich nicht für sehr
gescheit ich bin der Auffassung wir
brauchen immer wieder Leute die auch
Gesprächskanäle haben das hatten wir im
Übrigen immer zu allen Leuten auch
solche die überhaupt nicht gemocht haben
die also moralisch zu verurteilen sind
ich will also noch einen dann
draufsetzen wir dürfen die auch nicht
mit beiden verhandeln es verantwortlich
für die drohnenmorde Tausende
rechtswidrig ermordet also warum reden
wir mit dem wenn er also tausende
verantwortlich das Tausende rechtswidrig
ermordet werden dabei redet dann keiner
wir haben eine doppelte Moral die uns
also praktisch eine Sackgasse geführt
hat ja das machen sie seit langer Zeit
setzen immer wieder Russland mit den USA
gleich nennen die USA und auch den
Präsidenten einen Kriegsverbrecher
bleiben wir bitte bei der Frage nach
Gerhard Schröder Herr Lafontaine also
das heißt er war ja mehrfach in Moskau
war jetzt mehrfach wieder bei Putin er
könnte der
lösende Anker sein aus ihrer Sicht sie
würden ihren jetzt schicken als
Unterhändler als Verhandler
nein die die Initiative Muster von der
Bundesregierung ausgehen ich habe nur
darauf hingewiesen dass es günstig ist
wenn man Leute hat die eben Kontakte zu
anderen Personen haben die also
allgemein geächtet werden oder so es gab
immer die geheimt Diplomatie wenn es
sehr schwierig wurde und da sollte man
auf die Gesprächskanäle zurückgreifen
die man hat und insofern ist das für
mich eine pure Selbstverständlichkeit es
kann doch nicht sein dass man dem sage
ich mal moralisch einwandfreien Herrn
Erdogan es überlässt etwa
sicherzustellen dass getreidem mal
wieder geliefert wird in Länder die
dringend Getreide brauchen weil
Hungersnot herrscht es sollte jetzt
endlich mal die deutsche Politik wieder
zu Vernunft zurückkehren und Wissen man
kann keine feministische Außenpolitik
machen man muss Politik für die Menschen
in Deutschland machen und da muss man
eben einfach einen Weg finden dass
Energiepreise wieder bezahlbar werden so
einfach
sollte den Hut nehmen und sollte lieber
ein anderes Hobby pflegen als regieren
dann sollten Sie den Hut nehmen dann
sollten sollte der Harbeck den Hut
nehmen Frau bärbock sagt heller Fontaine
das einzige vernünftige was er gesagt
hat war dass am Ende Putin das
entscheidet alles andere was ich da
jetzt gehört habe war wenn man es ganz
freundlich ausdrücken will naiv und dann
wird aber irgendwelche Geschichten
erzählt wie als wie das wie ein Erdgas
im Bauhof hätten ich werde aber dafür
nämlich dann würden wir die handeln
werden alles haben wir gar nicht und ich
weiß nicht ob es
allen anderen entgangen ist aber Scholz
hat erst vor kurzem mit Putin geredet
telefoniert 19 Minuten immer mitbekommen
ganz genau und das hat auch nichts
gelöst
weil über Gas verhandeln das hat Scholz
natürlich in dem Telefonat
nach allem
geworden ist nicht getan aber bring mal
einen zweiten Mann ins Spiel wir haben
gerade über Gerd Schröder genau
gesprochen aus Skala von den wollte
nicht ganz offen sagen na das wäre jetzt
der richtige Mann in der Moskau zu
schicken hat ihn aber zwischen den
Zeilen da doch ein bisschen gelobt wenn
ich richtig zugehört habe was wäre mit
Joschka Fischer das ist halt als eine
absurde Vorstellung dass die Dinge nicht
miteinander verknüpft werden nämlich
vorher hieß es sozusagen in 70 Jahren
hat man noch keine
zweistellige Inflation erlebt naja aber
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg haben wir
halt auch nicht annähernd so einen Krieg
erlebt ja es gab den Zusammenbruch
Jugoslawiens Völkermorde und
schrecklichen Bürgerkrieg aber das ist
überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen ich
glaube man muss halt auch irgendwann mal
lernen zu akzeptieren dass wir einen
schrecklichen Krieg mitten in Europa
haben und das Russland auch schon länger
einen Hybriden Krieg gegen unsere jeden
Tag die Bilder das haben wir verstanden
Eindruck bei vielen auch dort auf der
Straße ist nachdem was unsere Reporter
dort berichten wir haben dann
Fachkräftemangel die irgendwie
Kompetenzzuweisung ist gerade sehr hoch
das haben die aktuellen Umfragen vor
allem wir haben Fachkräfte die wir
sozusagen hätten die haben wir ins
abstellfach gestellt und haben sie auch
nicht gut behandelt in den letzten
Monaten deshalb ist das Thema wir reden
über Politiker hier ne über
politikerfachspitzen spitzenpolizisten
wollen ins Abseits gestellt worden von
der eigenen Partei ist zum Teil auf
schäbige Weise
er hat Schröder geworden dass überhaupt
keine Frage das hat sich auch das tut
selber ins Abseits geschossen natürlich
hat er sich auch selber reingeschossen
aber das ist eine ganze Menge dazu getan
und das ist dumm Gewicht haben sie
Gesichter die durch ihre Meinung nach
durch die Krise führen könnten ja durch
die Krise führen muss die amtierende
Regierung das ist zunächst mal die
Regierungsverantwortung wenn sie sich
eines
Hilfsmittels und
hilfspersonals bedienen könnte und würde
dann würden in der Tat dafür Gerhard
Schröder da sein und würde auch Joschka
Fischer da aber haben wir gerade nur
nicht die Gesichter oder werden die
gerade in der in dieser Krise also wird
ein Haarwerk wird ein Scholz wird eine
Frau bärburg gerade zu diesen
charismatischen Figuren als die wir
später Genscher wahrgenommen haben und
Brand wahrgenommen haben und Helmut
Schmidt wahrgenommen ja ich weiß nicht
welche Zeitachse wir uns da vorstellen
in der dann diese charismatischen
Figuren entstehen sollen das im
Augenblick ist meine Fantasie was das
Charisma der beiden Personen angeht aber
ich möchte einen Punkt noch hinzufügen
der mir wichtig erscheint Herr
hofreiterweise alles immer so ganz
schnell abtun dass er beinahe schon
belustigend
ist keinen Grund zur Kritik Herr Habig
sagt selber die Komplexität des Themas
über steigt momentan seine Kapazitäten
und seine Fähigkeiten das erdinn dass er
das sagt aber dann muss man doch etwas
dagegen tun sie können doch auch nicht
von der Hand weisen dass wir eine
Koalition haben die maßlos zerstritten
ist und in dieser Frage wo es wirklich
um Gas geben beim Gas geht ständig auf
der Bremse steht FDP gegen grüne und
letzter Punkt Herr Hofreiter ihre Partei
hat dem guten Herrn Habig der uns ja
partiell schon leid tun kann immer
wieder
ja Knüppel zwischen die geworfen beim
Thema
Atomkraftwerke das hat die Fraktion
gemacht das hat die Basis gemacht ihr
seid immer noch dogmatisch sie sind beim
Thema Waffen sind sie plötzlich über
ihren Schatten gesprungen wunderbar
chapeau aber das andere da haben sie
doch ein HBG im Grunde im Regen stehen
lassen also ich muss sagen das ist
einfach wirklich
angesichts der Problematik vor der wir
stehen
angesichts dessen was ich vorher gesagt
habe dass wir ganze Reihe von Problemen
noch nicht gelöst haben und dann
erzählen Sie hier so Geschichte man es
geht einfach den Fakten nein eben genau
nicht man geht einfach drüber hinweg ich
habe sogar
gesagt ich gehe dann einfach sagt so
drüber hinweg das tue ich eben genau
nicht ich habe gerade gesagt dass er
ganze Reihe von Dingen noch nicht gelöst
hat und ich kann es auch ein drittes Mal
sagen zum Beispiel habe ich schon
Erkenntnis genommen
sie haben gerade vorher gesagt man geht
einfach so drüber weg und das ist das
was ich meinte man mit Angesicht
Schwierigkeit der Probleme angesichts
der irrenkomplexität angesichts dessen
dass wir mehrere Krisen parallel haben
wir haben zum Beispiel das Problem mit
den Kohlekraftwerken im Sommer gehabt
haben dass die Schiffe auf dem Rhein
immer fahren kann wegen der Klima und
dann sagen sie man geht dafür natürlich
gegangen auch die Grünen Minister um
genau diese Probleme zu lösen ist alles
zu schwierig nein sagt man auch nicht
aber
dann so zu tun als wenn die Regierung
sozusagen einfach gar nichts gemacht
hätte gar keinen Plan hätte so wie ich
es hier gehört habe nachdem wir ich kann
es noch mal wiederholen
flüssiggasterminals Kohlekraft haben wir
verstanden
sondern ich finde man muss das halt
ernst nehmen und dann nicht nach dem was
erläutert hat sagen nee die Regierung
hat gar keinen ich finde das eine sehr
ich finde das eine sehr ich finde das
eine sehr ernsthafte Diskussion
sozusagen daraus so reagiert moralisch
genug getan oder da gibt's noch eine
Lücke die moralisch auch spezifisch
die moralische Komponente in der Politik
die Moral in der Regierung ist die
soweit in den Vordergrund geraten dass
wir den ganzen Pragmatismus im Moment
nicht mehr sehen zu wenig sehen
ja das ist hier aber sie ist ja eben
noch grenzenlos verlogen also sie haben
vorhin Joschka Fischer angesprochen der
hat eine Zusammenarbeit mit Madeleine
Albright gehabt der Verstorbenen
US-Außenministerin diese Frau hat den
Tod von 500.000 Kindern im Irak durch
Sanktionen gerechtfertigt warum nicht
ein Riesengeschrei von Herrn Hofreiter
dass man mit einer solchen Frau
zusammenarbeiten kann dass man damit
diesen Tod von den Kindern ja auch noch
rechtfertigt ich bin also einfach
erschüttert über diese ungeheure
doppelte Moral die da ist wenn man also
Verbrechen verurteilt dann muss man sie
überall verurteilen bei Putin ja aber
nicht nur bei Putin auch bei den anderen
Kameraden die ich genannt haben die alle
für Völkerrecht für ihre Kriege und für
Morde und so weiter verantwortlich sind
ich habe es verstanden dass auch sie den
Kriegsverbrecher Putin dass sie kein Fan
von diesem Kriegsverbrecher Putin sind
wie Sie es sagen Herr Lafontaine
trotzdem die Frage wenn sie verhandeln
wollen ich bin ein Fan von Gorbatschow
dann müssen sie ja der ja leider
verstorben ist vor einigen Wochen jetzt
müssen wir von unseren Leuten weil da
das sagt etwas aus über die Moral der
deutschen Politik jetzt müssten sie aber
in solchen Verhandlungen Herrn Putin
oder seinen Leuten natürlich was
anbieten welches Zugeständnis würden sie
machen
für das Angebot Gas abzunehmen von ihnen
das ist ja ein Angebot für Sie denn sie
wollen natürlich nicht da sitzen und
ihre Verbindungen zu Europa was die
Rohstofflieferungen angeht eben auf
Dauer nicht mehr haben auch die Russen
sind angewiesen auf diese Lieferungen
und deswegen gilt eben der Satz das
Handel auch zum Frieden und zur
Verständigung beiträgt für etwas anderes
erzählt hat die Geschichte der letzten
Jahrzehnte nicht studiert
was könnte man
trotz Moral trotz Unterstützung für die
Ukraine gibt es irgendetwas was man
anbieten könnte in solchen Verhandlungen
weil das letztes Jahr voraus dass man
überhaupt in diese Verhandlung geht dass
man irgendwas auf dem Tisch legen kann
also ich habe mich heute schon relativ
weit vorgeworfen das ausgesprochen was
manche denken aber nicht auszusprechen
wagen wegen der öffentlichen Meinung
dass nach meinem Dafürhalten ich bin
Manager ich denke in Geldeinheiten aber
ich wollte auf die Frustration von Herrn
Hofreiter eingehen das Problem dass ich
ja oder ihr Unverständnis das Problem
dass ich hier sehe ist wir konzentrieren
alles auf Energie und Ukraine Tatsache
an Problemen an Problemen Ursache das
ist aber zu kurz gesprungen wir haben
grundsätzliche Verschiebungen im
globalen Wirtschaften ja das Pendel
schwingt gerade zurück wir haben
Probleme in unserer gesamten
logistischen Wertschöpfungskette und der
Exportweltmeister in Deutschland mal war
ja den navigiert jetzt zwischen Blöcken
USA und China ja und wird momentan
gerade richtig zerquetscht das will
keiner sehen ja und wir haben nicht mehr
die Infrastruktur die so viel besser ist
als in anderen Ländern wie es vor 20
Jahren war das ist die problemschichtung
dafür braucht eine genaue Analyse und
das ist was ich eingangs gesagt habe wir
brauchen einen Masterplan für dieses
Land und damit haben sie gerade genau
meine Kritik bestätigt keiner man
konzentriert sich überhaupt nicht darf
das stimmt halt nicht man hat zum
Beispiel die Probleme die wir durch die
Lieferketten mit China haben ganz massiv
im Blick da hat man noch nicht überall
die Lösungen wir haben zum Beispiel die
Probleme mit den Seltenen Erden die sehr
subventioniert werden in China aber dass
das keiner im Blick hat das ist halt
einfach falsch und auch da gilt es
nachdem man 16 Jahre des Land in immer
tiefere Abhängigkeit von China gefördert
kann man das nicht in neun Monaten
umkehren das geht halt nicht und deshalb
das alles was mich stört dass man
sozusagen Abhängigkeit von China wissen
Sie wie viel Arbeitsplätze in der
Automobilindustrie für China produzieren
wenn sich dann ein bisschen nur noch
mehr ändert dann sie
Massenarbeitslosigkeit hier wenn wir all
das Hören Herr Gottlieb wo stehen wir in
einigen Monaten in einem Jahr in einigen
Jahren hier in Deutschland ja gut das
hängt massiv natürlich von der Zukunft
unserer energieausstattung ab das ist
der entscheidende Punkt über dem wir
heute abend diskutiert haben ich sehe
aber ein weiteres aber wo sehen Sie
persönlich wir haben ja im Ende Richtung
anhand der wir die Politik messen können
anhand der wir ein bisschen in die
Zukunft blicken können also wo landen
wir gerade
sie meinen jetzt in der Regierung oder
als Land wir alles Deutschland landen
das ist im Augenblick ganz ganz schwer
einzuschätzen das müssen wir natürlich
abhängig machen von der Energie
Situation und im Augenblick sieht es
dramatisch aus sage ich mal mit Blick
auch auf die Unternehmer im Lande
absolut dramatisch da haben wir nur
einen ganz begrenzten Einblick und da
haben wir auch ein Riesenproblem weil
wir zwei Regierungschefs hatten die
zusammen über 30 Jahre reagiert hat
nämlich Frau Merkel und Herrn Kohl beide
haben kein Interesse an der Wirtschaft
gehabt das muss man so sehen
die haben der eine war Historiker die
andere war Physikerin sie hatten kein
Interesse an der Wirtschaft und ich sage
jetzt noch mal was auch die Medien haben
natürlich insgesamt zu wenig Interesse
an wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhängen und
das tut natürlich diesem Land und Ihrer
Frage wohin führt es denn natürlich
alles andere und genau das vertiefen sie
und damit rechnen sie ab auch in ihrem
neuen Buch so nicht heißt das
tatsächlich eine Abrechnung mit der
Bundesregierung bei dem ich mich nur
gefragt habe warum das wenn sie so lange
im Journalismus waren so lange
Chefredakteur waren erst jetzt kommt
ganz kurze Antwort warum weil ich jetzt
die Muse erzählt mit mit genügend Leuten
zurück jetzt können Sie die Menschen der
Politik streng auf den Finger schauen
Oskar Lafontaine wo landet das Land war
die Frage wirtschaftlich wir sehen
anderswo und Rechtsruck beispielsweise
in Italien aktuell ist das auch unsere
Zukunft hier in den nächsten Monaten
Jahren
wenn wenn das so weitergeht ist das eine
große Gefahr das lehrt uns die
Geschichte wenn Massenverarmung Eintritt
Massenarbeitslosigkeit wenn das
Vertrauen in die Regierung sinkt dann
wird die rechte stark insofern geht es
also erstens einmal um die armen Leute
den wir helfen müssen zweitens um den
Wirtschaftsstandort den wir retten
müssen eine Industriestaat und
deutschland ist einer der wichtigsten
Industriestaaten der Welt braucht
preiswerte Energie und preiswerte
Rohstoffe aber drittens geht es auch um
die politische Stabilität die jetzige
Politik der Ampel führt zum Erstarken
der rechten das werden wir in den
nächsten Monaten sehen das wird alles
andere wird ihr Bestreben sein nicht
dass Herr Hofreiter werden Sie dieses
Problem in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten lösen werden Sie diese große
Probleme wird man lösen denn man darf
nicht vergessen wir haben sehr viel
billige Energie in unserem Land und die
müssen wir jetzt schnell ausbauen das
Photovoltaik produziert Ihnen den Strom
für zwei Cent
braucht für vier bis fünf Cent und das
muss man jetzt schnell heben nämlich
beim Strom produzieren gerade sehr viele
sehr viel günstige Energie wir müssen
dazu die Marktmechanismen ändern nicht
die Leute können das nicht mehr zahlen
und es kann nicht sein dass ein
Unternehmen dessen Strom für drei Cent
produziert in für 70 Cent verkaufen und
gigantische überschüssigen
heute noch mal bei Bild bei den
richtigen Fragen